sometimes it feels like the universe is
just messing with you I have up on
screen here a sequence of computations
and don't worry in a moment we're going
to unpack and visualize what each one is
really saying what I want you to notice
is how the sequence follows a very
predictable if random seeming pattern
and how each computation happens to
equal pi and if you were just messing
around evaluating these on a computer
for some reason you might think that
this was a pattern that would go on
forever but it doesn't at some point it
stops and instead of equaling Pi you get
a value which is just barely barely less
than pi
all right let's dig into what's going on
here the main character in the story
today is the function sine of x divided
by X this actually comes up commonly
enough in math and Engineering that it
gets its own name sync and the way you
might think about it is by starting with
a normal oscillating sine curve and then
sort of squishing it down as you get far
away from zero by multiplying it by 1
over X and the astute among you might
ask about what happens at x equals zero
since when you plug that in it looks
like dividing Zero by zero and then the
even more is dude among you may be fresh
out of a Calculus class could point out
that for values closer and closer to
zero the function gets closer and closer
to one so if we simply redefine the sync
function at 0 to equal one you get a
nice continuous curve all of that is a
little by the by because the thing we
actually care about is the integral of
this curve from negative Infinity to
Infinity which you'd think of as meaning
the area between the curve and the
x-axis or more precisely the signed area
meaning you add all the area Bound by
the positive parts of the graph in the
x-axis and you subtract all of the parts
Bound by the negative parts of the graph
and the x-axis like we saw at the start
it happens to be the case that this
evaluates to be exactly Pi which is nice
and also a little weird and it's not
entirely clear how you would approach
this with the usual tools of calculus
towards the end of the video I'll share
the trick for how you would do this
progressing on with the sequence I
opened with the next step is to take a
copy of the sync function where you plug
in x divided by 3 which will basically
look like the same graph but stretched
out horizontally by a factor of three
when we multiply these two functions
together we get a much more complicated
wave whose Mass seems to be more
concentrated towards the middle and with
any usual functions you would expect
this completely changes the area you
can't just randomly modify an integral
like this and expect nothing to change
so already it's a little bit weird that
this result also equals Pi that nothing
has changed that's another mystery you
should add to your list and the next
step in the sequence was to take an even
more stretched out version of the sync
function by a factor 5 multiply that by
what we already have and again look at
the signed area underneath the whole
curve which again equals pi
and it continues on like this with each
iteration we stretch out by a new odd
number and multiply that into what we
have one thing you might notice is how
except that the input x equals zero
every single part of this function is
progressively getting multiplied by
something that's smaller than one
so you would expect as the sequence
progresses for things to get squished
down more and more and if anything you
would expect the area to be getting
smaller
eventually that is exactly what happens
but what's bizarre is that it stays so
stable for so long and of course more
pertinently that when it does break at
the value 15 it does so by the tiniest
tiny amount and before you go thinking
this is the result of some numerical
error maybe because we're doing
something with floating Point arithmetic
if you work this out more precisely here
is the exact value of that last integral
which is a certain fraction of Pi where
the numerator and the denominator are
absurd they're both around 400 billion
billion billion
so this pattern was described in a paper
by a father-son pair Jonathan and David
borwain which is very fun and they
mentioned how when a fellow researcher
was Computing these integrals using a
computer algebra system he assumed that
this had to be some kind of bug but it's
not a bug it is a real phenomenon and it
gets weirder than that actually if we
take all these integrals and include yet
another Factor 2 cosine of x which again
you would think changes their values
entirely you can't just randomly
multiply new things into an integral
like this it continues to equal Pi for
much much longer and it's not until you
get to the number 113 that it breaks and
when it breaks it's by the most puny
absolutely subtle amount that you could
imagine
so the natural question is what on Earth
is going on here and luckily there
actually is a really satisfying
explanation for all this the way I think
I'll go about this is to show you a
phenomenon that first looks completely
unrelated but it shows a similar pattern
where you have a value that stays really
stable until you get to the number 15
and then it falters by just a tiny
amount and then after that I'll show why
this seemingly unrelated phenomenon is
secretly the same as all our integral
Expressions but in Disguise so turning
our attention to what seems completely
different consider a function that I'm
going to be calling rect of X which is
defined to equal one if the input is
between negative one-half and one-half
and otherwise it's equal to zero so the
function is this boring step basically
this will be the first in a sequence of
functions that we Define so I'll call it
F1 of X and each new function in our
sequence is going to be a kind of moving
average of the previous function
so for example the way the second
iteration will be defined is to take
this sliding window whose width is
one-third and for a particular input X
when the window is centered at that
input X the value in my new function
drawn below is defined to be equal to
the average value of the first function
above inside that window so for example
when the window is far enough to the
left every value inside it is zero so
the graph on the bottom is showing zero
as soon as that window starts to go over
the plateau a little bit the average
value is a little more than zero and you
see that in the graph below and notice
that when exactly half the window is
over that Plateau at one and half of it
is at zero the corresponding value in
the bottom graph is one half and you get
the point the important thing I want you
to focus on is how when that window is
entirely in the plateau above where all
the values are one then the average
value is also one so we get this Plateau
on our function at the bottom let's call
this bottom function F2 of X and what I
want you to think about is the length of
the plateau for that second function how
wide should it be if you think about it
for a moment the distance between the
left edge of the top plateau and the
left edge of the bottom Plateau will be
exactly half of the width of the window
so half of one-third and similarly on
the right side the distance between the
edges of the plateaus is half of the
window width so overall it's one minus
that window width which is one minus a
third
the value we're going to be Computing
the thing that will look stable for a
while before it breaks is the value of
this function at the input 0 which in
both of these iterations is equal to 1
because it's inside that Plateau for the
next iteration we're going to take a
moving average of that last function but
this time with the window whose width is
one-fifth it's kind of fun to think
about why as you slide around this
window you get a smoothed out version of
the previous function and again the
significant thing I want you to focus on
is how when that window is entirely
inside the plateau of the previous
function then by definition the bottom
function is going to equal 1. this time
the length of that Plateau on the bottom
will be the length of the previous one 1
minus a third minus the window width
one-fifth the reasoning is the same as
before in order to go from the point
where the middle of the window is on
that top Plateau to where the entirety
of the window is inside that Plateau is
half the window width and likewise on
the right side and once more the value
to record is the output of this function
when the input is zero which again is
exactly one
the next iteration is a moving average
with a window width of 1 7 the plateau
gets smaller by that one over seven
doing one more iteration with one over
nine the plateau gets smaller by that
amount and as we keep going the plateau
gets thinner and thinner
and also notice how just outside of the
plateau the function is really really
close to one because it's always been
the result of an average between the
plateau at 1 and the Neighbors which
themselves are really really close to
one
the point at which all of this breaks is
once we get to the iteration where we're
sliding a window with width 1 15 across
the whole thing
at that point the previous Plateau is
actually thinner than the window itself
so even at the input x equals zero this
moving average will have to be ever so
slightly smaller than one and the only
thing that's special about the number 15
here is that as we keep adding the
reciprocals of these odd fractions
one-third plus one-fifth Plus
one-seventh on and on it's once we get
to 1 15 that that sum grows to be bigger
than one and in the context of our
shrinking plateaus having started with a
plateau of width one it's now shrunk
down so much that it'll disappear
entirely the point is with this is a
sequence of functions that we've defined
by a seemingly random procedure if I ask
you to compute the values of all of
these functions at the input 0 you get a
pattern which initially looks stable
it's one one one one one one one one but
by the time we get to the eighth
iteration it falls short ever so
slightly just barely
this is analogous and I claim more than
just analogous to the integrals we saw
earlier where we have a stable value at
Pi Pi Pi Pi Pi until it falls short just
barely and as it happens this constant
from our moving average process that's
ever so slightly smaller than one is
exactly the factor that sits in front of
Pi in our series of integrals so the two
situations aren't just qualitatively
similar they're quantitatively the same
as well and when it comes to the case
where we add the two cosine of x term
inside the integral which caused the
pattern to last a lot longer before it
broke down in the analogy what that will
correspond to is the same setup but
where the function we start with has an
even longer Plateau stretching from x
equals negative one up to 1 meaning its
length is two so as you do this repeated
moving average process eating into it
with the smaller and smaller Windows it
takes a lot longer for them to eat into
the whole Plateau more specifically the
relevant computation is to ask how long
do you have to add these reciprocals of
odd numbers until that sum becomes
bigger than two and it turns out that
you have to to go until you hit the
number 113 which will correspond to the
fact that the integral pattern there
continues until you hit 113.
and by the way I should emphasize that
there is nothing special about these
reciprocals of odd numbers one third
one-fifth one-seventh that just happens
to be the sequence of values highlighted
by the borwains in their paper that made
the sequence mildly famous in nerd
circles more generally we could be
inserting any sequence of positive
numbers into those sync functions and as
long as the sum of those numbers is less
than one our expression will equal Pi
but as soon as they become bigger than
one our expression drops a little below
pi and if you believe me that there's an
analogy with these moving averages you
can hopefully see why foreign
but of course the burning question is
why on Earth should these two situations
have anything to do with each other from
here the argument does bring in two
mildly heavy bits of Machinery namely
Fourier transforms and convolutions and
the way I'd like to go about this is to
spend the remainder of this video giving
you a high level sense of how the
argument will go without necessarily
assuming you're familiar with either of
those two topics and then to explain why
the details are true in a video that's
dedicated to convolutions in particular
something called the convolution theorem
since it's incredibly beautiful and it's
useful well beyond this specific very
esoteric question
to start instead of focusing on this
function sine of x divided by X where we
want to show why the signed area
underneath its curve is equal to Pi
we'll make a simple substitution where
we replace the input x with pi times x
which has the effect of squishing the
graph horizontally by a factor of Pi and
so the area gets scaled down by a factor
of Pi meaning our new goal is to show y
this integral on the right is equal to
exactly one by the way in some
engineering contexts people use the name
sync to refer to this function with the
pi on the inside since it's often very
nice to have a normalized function
meaning the area under it is equal to
one the point is showing this integral
on the right is exactly the same thing
as showing the integral on the left it's
just a change of variables and likewise
for all of the other ones in our
sequence go through each of them replace
the X with a pi times x
and from here the claim is that all
these integrals are not just analogous
to the moving average examples but that
both of these are two distinct ways of
computing exactly the same thing and the
connection comes down to the fact that
this sync function or the engineer sync
function with the pi on the inside is
related to the rect function using
what's known as a Fourier transform now
if you've never heard of a Fourier
transform there are a few other videos
on this channel all about it the way
it's often described is that if you want
to break down a function as the sum of a
bunch of pure frequencies or in the case
of an infinite function a continuous
integral of a bunch of pure frequencies
the Fourier transform will tell you all
the strength and phases for all those
constituent Parts but all you really
need to know here is that it is
something which takes in one function
and spits out a new function and you
often think of it as kind of rephrasing
the information of your original
function in a different language like
you're looking at it from A New
Perspective for example like I said this
sync function written in this new
language where you take a Fourier
transform looks like our Top Hat rect
function and vice versa by the way this
is a nice thing about Fourier transforms
for functions that are symmetric about
the y-axis it is its own inverse and
actually the slightly more general fact
that we'll need to show is how when you
transform the stretched out version of
our sync function where you stretch it
horizontally by a factor of K what you
get is a stretched and squished version
of this rect function but of course all
of these are just meaningless words in
terminology unless you can actually do
something upon making this translation
and the real idea behind why Fourier
transforms are such a useful thing for
math is that when you take statements
and questions about a particular
function and then you look at what they
correspond to with respect to the
transformed version of that function
those statements and questions often
look very very different in this new
language and sometimes it makes the
questions a lot easier to answer for
example one very nice little fact
another thing on our list of things to
show is that if you want to compute the
integral of some function from negative
Infinity to Infinity this signed area
under the entirety of its curve it's the
same thing as simple evaluating the
Fourier transformed version of that
function at the input 0. this is a fact
that will actually just pop right out of
the definition and it's representative
of a more General vibe that every
individual output of the Fourier
transform function on the right
corresponds to some kind of global
information about the original function
on the left in our specific case it
means if you believe me that this sync
function and the rect function are
related with a Fourier transform like
this it explains the integral which is
otherwise a very tricky thing to compute
because it's saying all that signed area
is the same thing as evaluating rect at
zero which is just one
now you could complain surely this just
moves the bump under the rug surely
Computing this 48 transform whatever
that looks like would be as hard as
Computing the original integral but the
idea is that there's lots of tips and
tricks for computing these Fourier
transforms and moreover that when you do
it tells you a lot more information than
just that integral you get a lot of bang
for your buck out of doing the
computation now the other key fact that
will explain the connection we're
hunting for is that if you have two
different functions and you take their
product and then you take the Fourier
transform of that product it will be the
same thing as if you individually took
the Fourier transforms of your original
function and then combine them using a
new kind of operation that we'll talk
all about in the next video known as a
convolution now even though there's a
lot to be explained with convolutions
the upshot will be that in our specific
case with these rectangular functions
taking a convolution looks just like one
of the moving averages that we've been
talking about this whole time combined
with our previous fact that integrating
in one context looks like evaluating at
zero in another context if you believe
me that multiplying in one context
corresponds to this new operation
convolutions which for our example you
should just think of as moving averages
that will explain why multiplying more
and more of these sync functions
together can be thought about in terms
of these Progressive moving averages and
always evaluating at zero which in turn
gives A really lovely intuition for why
you would expect such a stable value
before eventually something breaks down
as the edges of the plateau inch closer
and closer to the center
this last key fact by the way has a
special name it's called the convolution
theorem and again it's something that
will go into much more deeply
I recognize that it's maybe a little
unsatisfying to end things here by
laying down three magical facts and
saying everything follows from those but
hopefully this gives you a little
glimpse of why powerful tools like
Fourier transforms can be so useful for
tricky problems
it's a systematic way to provide a shift
in perspective where hard problems can
sometimes look easier if nothing else it
hopefully provides some motivation to
learn about these beautiful things like
the convolution theorem as one more tiny
teaser another fun consequence of this
convolution theorem will be that it
opens the doors for an algorithm that
lets you compute the product of two
large numbers very quickly like way
faster than you think should be even
possible
so with that I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]